how to overcome your fears
so i got a great question from one of my
youtube viewers love you guys amal who
wrote in to say
thanks for this great video and please
could you do a video about fear
i mean how to not be scared to do some
skills and to have that courage to do
what you want to do
i'm a gymnast and i'm scared to learn
backwards skills and i want to improve
and be a good gymnast more than anything
so please if you have anything that can
help me even a motivational text
have a nice day so this is a great
question and and amal i really
i really fear for you because you're not
alone
you know fear is something that holds
holds people back from achieving
great things in our lives anything that
you do that is big is gonna come with a
healthy dose of fear and that's natural
and that
that is normal and you have to bust
through that to achieve great things
because your life is here and to get
here
there's a lot of unknown and unknown
equals fear
so how do you get through that step
number one is remember why you're doing
it
your why has to be important why do you
want to do this so if you're a gymnast
why is being a good gymnast important to
you what do you want to accomplish with
your life
right if you're an entrepreneur why is
that important you want to launch a
business hey it's going to be hard
why is this so important to you are you
doing it to have an impact in the world
are you doing it for your kids are you
doing it because
you know your your dad died of this
disease and now you want to go out and
solve it why are you doing this
if you have a big enough why then the
fear becomes smaller
because you're here and you want to get
here and the only thing stopping you is
your fear
if this is super important to you then
that fear
shrinks yeah you're still going to be
afraid and
everybody's still going to be afraid
okay someone tells you no i'm not afraid
of anything
they're lying along that path you're
going to be afraid
but you push through the fear because
that end goal is important to you
okay that's first remember why two
no regrets i try to live my life with no
regrets
and and i think people should too
because you look at people
when they're in their 70s or 80s and and
you know they're on their deathbed
they're
they're breathing their last breath and
you talk to them and they're looking
back on their lives and
one of the most common things that
people say on their death bed
is they wish they took more chances
they wish that they took that
opportunity they wish they took action
on this idea they had
instead of just staying in the status
quo i don't want to be that guy
i don't want to be the guy who when i'm
on my deathbed i look back on my life
and i say wow i wish i went and did that
i had a dream i had a goal i wish i
chased it
so fast forward your life to 70 80 years
old and look back
if you don't learn these backflips
and you don't become a great gymnast
it's not going to haunt you for the rest
of your life
probably will and again it's not that
the fear goes away the fear is still
there just becomes smaller
because you don't want to be that person
looking back in your life wishing you
had gone for it
no regrets number three is get help
having people help you
makes a goal easier to go and accomplish
and it could be somebody you know if i
were you i go to find a gymnast find a
gymnast who's done this
who knows how to do backflips and tell
them you know what i want to be a great
gymnast i'm working hard i'm killing
myself i'm trying to make this happen
i'm just afraid
of doing the backflips can you help me
and having somebody who's gone through
it does two things one
it it gives you confidence
and technique and that they're showing
you the right way to do something
right you're learning from somebody
who's done it so the chances of you
doing it wrong
go down so i can decrease your fear but
also
just being accountable to somebody
right a lot of times our goals we keep
to ourselves because we're too afraid to
share with other people
because when we tell somebody then we
better go out and do it
that accountability is good having
somebody there to help you
just even if they don't know what
they're doing and that skill set that
you're trying to learn just
just to be accountable to to tell that
person yeah i'm making progress or i'm
not and they hold your feet to the fire
because you don't want to tell them
yeah i'm still afraid i'm still afraid
at some point you're gonna be like
i gotta just do this so get help
and number four is break it down and i
found that this helps me a lot where
you know you're here again and you have
this goal to be up here
and you see this huge fear
in between because it's it's giant step
to get to
to where you want to be from where you
are the reality is you're not going to
take this one giant step
it's going to be a little step and a
little step and a little step and a
little step
and eventually you're going to be up
here where you want to be but through a
series of little steps
and taking a little step is a lot less
scary than taking that big step so
break it down what do you need to do
that is the next smallest simplest
easiest step
that you might be a little bit afraid of
but you can get through
and once you've done that then
you can do it again you're not afraid of
it anymore because you've done it and
you can take the next step and then take
the next step up
so if you're a gymnast you're afraid of
doing a backflip how can you break that
backflip down
how can you break that down to something
simpler
where you're still going backwards or
maybe not doing a full flip i don't know
what it is
break it down so if you get halfway
there and you can do that consistently
then you can go all the way
here's a quick example i um one of my
first
speaking engagements internationally was
in brunei and i was
asked to go over there and speak and
i've been used to doing you know small
sessions
and here it was going to be i don't know
1000 people i don't know when people in
the room was it was broadcast nationally
on their tv stations it was over two
days and i
i get up on stage and i'm i'm i'm like
freaking out
before that happened i kind of secretly
wish that they would cancel on me
you know like the day before my flight
say oh evan it's off you don't have to
come you know kind of
put all my fears to worry to rest
and i got up there and i knew that she
ended up being great
you know i didn't i didn't choke i
didn't throw up you know
but i was still scared i pushed through
the fear
but now i know i could do it again right
it was scary the first time but it's not
so scary anymore
scary might be packing the stadium at
madison square gardens you know i might
be scared doing that
but if i do it once and i'll be okay i
can do it again so same thing for you
right break it down find an easy step
to help you get started then the next
steps
and the next steps aren't as scary as
you go forward
so that's my advice and i hope you i
hope you push through because
fear is a really dangerous thing and
it's a dream killer
and holds people back from being the
people they could be
believe for those who watching like the
video thumbs up below
let me know how you deal with your fear
i'm really curious your strategy is
what's worked for you what hasn't worked
for you leave it in the comments below i
want to hear from you
and you want to see more videos like
this click on my face subscribe to the
channel thank you so much
i'll see you soon
you